e aí
o meu inicia dizendo que o brasil é o
sétimo país mais desigual do mundo
vivemos dias muito duro difíceis para
aqueles que sobrevivem com tão pouco
sempre as margens as desigualdades entre
elas a econômica social e racial são
fatores preponderantes e do atual
momento falando diretamente do cuidado
com a saúde segundo o ibge estima-se que
cerca de 34 milhões de família são
chefiados por mulheres no brasil
ferreira no centro as batalhas do
dia-a-dia nessa sociedade onde o
machismo o racismo o sexismo caminho de
mãos dadas cruéis formas de opressão
luto aqui é verbo
oi maria carolina de jesus lá em 1960 o
seu livro quarto de despejo já dizia as
crianças ricas brincam no jardins com
seus brinquedos prediletos e as crianças
pobres acompanham as mães a pedirem as
bolas pelas ruas que desigualdades
trágica e brincadeira do destino o
brasil precisa ser governado por uma
pessoa que já passou fome por esses
trechos porque eles representam muito
bem a realidade que eu tenho vivido nas
ruas o pênis barro das comunidades
eu tenho deparado com as mais diversas
formas de violência e violação ao
empobrecimento de um povo que grita alto
e não é houve falta de oportunidade
desemprego as crianças nas ruas é a some
a urgência do dia de quem me digam quem
consegue pensar no futuro assim para
todos os cantos que eu olho eu me vejo
no rosto de cada uma dessas mulheres
anas fernandas maria luiza eu sou uma
delas agora sanitarista educadora social
mas por muito muito tempo trabalhei
diretamente com a população em situação
de rua já acompanhei inúmeras situações
de violência e violações de direito mas
como uma pandemia trouxe o pior e
deflagrou esse estado de miséria
e no contexto estamos emergiu de forma
muito rápida fome e com ela necessidade
de execução de ações concretas o
isolamento que para uns é no conforto
das suas casas para outros é privação em
espaços tão insalubres que eu não sei
nem por onde começar a relatar
considerando a minha experiência de vida
e também por ser moradora da periferia
eu decidi ir para são é que eu iniciei
um movimento de arrecadação junto com
algumas parceiras nós vamos de porta em
porta e todos os campos que é para
garantir que esse auxílio shane a quem
realmente precisa são muitas mulheres
idosos crianças pessoas com mobilidade
reduzida deficientes físicos e visuais
são ruim é pensam em promover o cuidado
e seguimos assim com olhar as tempo
respeito e responsabilidade tem muito
carinho que a gente faz aliás
em todas as pessoas na estação nos
exatamente como nós gostaríamos de ser
tratados essas ações fazem parte de um
projeto que eu idealizei e atualmente
coordeno tem um fundo limpar as mulheres
aqui em porto alegre e também na região
metropolitana o que me move é essa
vontade da transformação me movo porque
a impossível pactuar com a barbalha
nós somos nós coletivas ou melhor
coletivo cláudia ferreira e adverso em
sua composição e que está ativo nas
periferias carrega esse nome em
homenagem a uma mulher preta que era
auxiliar de serviços gerais mãe de
quatro filhos e cuidava de 4 sobrinhos
ela foi morta violentamente em março de
2014 quando saiu para comprar pão a pior
coisa do mundo é o sono
o outro dia estávamos bem em nenhuma
comunidade organizando as entregas de
cestas roupas máscaras e tudo mais
quando avistei de longe uma mulher
puxando um carrinho aparecia lado
distante para que tinha uma criança
beleza me aproximei é uma mulher negra
aparentava ter uns 35 anos magra com
mais ou menos um metro e meio de altura
foi chegando mais perto e ela com os
olhos fixos em mim olha os cansados e
para ser bem sincera nem poderia ser
diferente carrinho era enorme
eu e ela que estava sozinha
e parece-me um tanto assustada eu
perguntei o seu nome luciana vai ser o
nome que tinha isso dela
oi hoje observar rapidamente as mãos
fortes calejados e quem carrega muito
peso quem faz força não usava luva nem
máscaras em campos economia parece que o
cuidado não está disponível para todos
e para minha surpresa olhando bem
observar que não é apenas uma criança
assim duas crianças com aquele carrinho
perdidas em meio àquela montanha de
materiais reciclagem com segundo pensei
nos meus sobrinhos crianças que quase
imperceptíveis disfarçadas em meio a
todo aquele material
as duas crianças tão pequenas que
pareciam se divertir e achar graça o que
me fato até possa ser verdade é o lúdico
que salva em algumas situações tem que
para alguns é até difícil de imaginar
mas considerando que alguns espaços por
onde nós temos passado lazer é luxo
andar de carrinho deve ser quase que um
parque de diversões
o ator meritocracia a falta de acesso às
possibilidades que não são iguais são
tantas as coisas que atravessam a
infância futuro por vezes eu me sinto
tão triste respiro e sim
oi luciana logo bem meu gato me disse as
crianças estão comigo porque é
impossível deixar elas em casa são muito
pequenos e não sabem se defender os
maiores se viram bem diz ela vai saber a
realidade das mães trabalhadoras da
periferia e sobe um pouco mais e ela me
falou que a mãe de três crianças cuida
de dois sobrinhos fica agora atualmente
sozinha trabalha com a reciclagem para
poder sustentar a família e ainda escola
agora sou eu e deus depois de ficar
alguns segundos me olhando e falar da
cor do meu cabelo nitidamente mais
confortável prosseguiu sabe eu entendo
que não é certo trazer as crianças são
muito pequenos eu já fui informada que
eu não posso fazer isso
e mais alguns anos atrás eu deixei meu
filho mais velho em casa ele tinha seis
anos bem um copo de leite para o menino
que ficou dormindo na época de vela
saímos eu e meu companheiro bem cedinho
da manhã para trabalhar na rua porque
para fazer um troco tem que sair cedo de
casa estamos fora até perto do meio-dia
e quando voltamos só estavam a cinzas da
casa
e não descuido perder tudo não posso
correr esse risco outra vez
e essa situação dói em mim como uma
fratura exposta
o gaba quilombo disse o mito de que as
pessoas negras se utilizam quando falam
das suas feridas causadas pelo racismo é
uma estratégia cruel para silenciá-los
esse é o que eu sinto é a vontade de
transformar essa sociedade e fazer desse
lugar menos desigual que me move para um
lugar melhor para todos nós todos nós e
me coloco à disposição dessa
transformação porque eu acredito eu tô
falando isso porque eu não tenho muita
grana eu trabalho todos os dias para
garantir o real e ainda assim me saiu o
movimento aqui hoje até hoje já atendeu
mais de duas mil e quinhentas famílias
eu sei que muitas outras ainda precisão
mas se cada um de nós acreditar que é
possível e se unir a outras pessoas
organizações espaço que já estão
buscando ações o iniciar o movimento a
partir do lugar que ocupa pensa compacto
lindo a gente pode promover nessa
sociedade
e eu falo isso assim porque eu realmente
acredito e que a responsabilidade também
a nossa é por isso que convoca cada um
de vocês que tá indo ou vindo agora e
faça parte dessa mudança a gente precisa
ser a revolução hoje vem aqui exaltar e
também agradecer todas essas mulheres
minha vida a força dança astralidade que
me guia a vida
hoje e sempre me deu essas referências
maravilhosas e mulheres tão fortes que
me encorajaram minha avó helena as
marias minhas tias minha mãe pressa
tantas mulheres que me ensinou a
escrever à mão a ser forte e acreditar e
a lutar exemplos de mulheres definidas
nunca me faltaram
e nessa vida eu sigo com respeito
responsabilidade acesso um dia de cada
vez tudo isso me fez escolher o trabalho
com e para as mulheres porque em todos
os momentos eu falo de mim porque sempre
somos nós o tempo todo